um mr hitchens are you hopeful at all
that uh
henry kissinger will be brought to trial
sometime in his lifetime
uh well
the question was whether i hoped to see
henry kissinger brought to trial
um
yeah i mean i used to hope he would die
and now i hope he lives because
because i think that there's every
chance that uh some of it will catch up
to him i can give you an update at any
rate um on memorial day last year
i'm proud to say just after my book came
out in french
he was visited by the jean d'armarie in
the ritz hotel in paris on a good
warrant
from judge liloa
um and serve the summons to appear as a
witness in a hearing about the
disappeared french people in chile of
whom they're quite a number
he chose not to answer the summons and
fled town but it's still extant when he
goes back to france that's one of one of
the countries he now can't go to
the brazilian government recently uh
before the last election that is the
last brazilian election the brazilian
government asked him to cancel a visit
that he'd been invited to make they're
on the grounds that his immunity from
prosecution couldn't be guaranteed
the judge in the pinochet case in chile
the great judge guzman
has sent him a summons for questioning
so has judge rodolfo corral
the great judge in the case of the death
squads in argentina the laws of many
european countries including federal
germany have meanwhile changed
so that it is the responsibility of any
court uh to apprehend anyone wanted for
war crimes or crimes against humanity
wherever they are
and a sporting attempt was made to
arrest sir when he was in london
last but he he left the judge was
considering it when he when he left in
other words
the atmosphere around the bastard has
shrunk quite a lot the oxygen is
thinning around him
he can't travel and posture in quite the
way he used to and a lawsuit
has been filed against him in washington
dc
in federal court
by the family of um general renee
schneider
formerly head of the general staff in
chile a constitutional democratic
officer who
didn't favor a coup against the olynyk
government who was murdered uh shot down
in the street on henry kissinger's
direct orders his family has brought a
suit
for murder wrongful death in washington
every document in the suit every
document in the affidavit in other words
of the of the prosecution is a us
government declassified document i think
that's the first time
i think that's the first time uh that's
been possible to say that we have him
cold in other words
so the question is cheering though this
is um
[Music]
i leave it as a question to everybody
here it's very nice to know
that there are many foreign courts
pursuing these questions and it's nice
to know that chileans
who've already suffered at his hands are
having to bring their own
lawsuit in washington
but isn't it a bit of a disgrace that
there's no us government
department
no congressional committee no new
american district attorney who is
thinking why are we sheltering
a wanted war criminal why is the united
states a safe haven for someone wanted
for crimes against humanity it's an
important question i'll leave it with
you